it's lab muffin here your resident
beauty science nerd and today we're
going to be talking about visible light
more specifically we're going to be
talking about blue light and what that
does to your skin we all know about UV
rays from the Sun damaging your skin and
you might have also heard of infrared
radiation but what about the wavelengths
of light that we can actually see will
they damage your skin how can you
protect your skin from visible light
let's take a closer look the Sun
produces a lot of light as well as the
wavelengths of light that we can see
which is called visible light
there's also ultraviolet or UV light
which has shorter wavelengths and higher
energy UV is one of the main causes of
aging skin on the other side at longer
wavelengths than visible light there's
low energy infrared or IR radiation the
energy from the Sun that we get on earth
is about three to seven percent UV 44%
visible light and 53% infrared even
though there's less UV in total UV ends
up causing more damage because each
individual UV particle or photon has
more energy it's like being hit with a
single bullet or being hit with a bunch
of balled up tissues that way the same as
ten bullets but there's been more
research that's been finding that
visible and infrared wavelengths can
also cause skin damage
so why is blue light the color that
everyone's interested in and not the
other colors like red or yellow? most of
the time when people say blue light what
they really mean is blue and violet
light and the reason why these colors
are more damaging is because of physics
shorter wavelengths of electromagnetic
radiation from the Sun have more energy
in sunlight UV has the shortest
wavelengths which is up to 400
nanometers visible light is longer from
400 to 700 nanometers so it's lower in
energy
infrared has longer wavelengths from 700
nanometers to 1 millimeter and out of
these 3 it has the lowest energy if we
zoom into the visible light region the
order of the colors is ROYGBIV red
orange yellow green blue indigo and
violet infrared is past the red end
while ultraviolet is past the violet
end blue and violet have the shortest
wavelengths of the visible region around
400 to 500 nanometers and therefore out
of all of these colors it's got the
highest energy so these colors of light
are the ones that are the most likely to
cause damage that's similar to the UV
sun damage that we've been researching
for years and years because of their
higher energy blue and violet light is
often called HEV light which stands for
high-energy visible light
the research on the impact of blue and
visible light on your skin isn't as
advanced as the research on UV so it's a
bit less clear exactly how it causes
damage to your skin and to make it more
confusing older studies on the effects
of blue light aren't as valid because
the electromagnetic spectrum is a
continuous spectrum there isn't any sort
of strict divide between
ultraviolet and visible-light except for
what human eyes can and can't see a lot
of the time the lights used in the older
studies actually produce UV as well as
blue and violet light this means that
the effects that they found could have
been from the stray UV light and not
actually because of the visible blue and
violet light at all here's what the
research shows so far about light and
skin just like how UVA and UVB have
different effects on the skin different
parts of the visible light spectrum can
also have different effects depending on
their wavelength which translates to
color or energy different colors in the
visible light spectrum can even have
opposite effects on your skin here's
what the studies have found in cultured
human skin cells in in vitro studies
blue light caused skin cells to die
while red light had no effect in animal
studies blue light slowed down skin
recovery after it was irritated while
red light sped it up and green and white
light didn't make a difference in people
with dark skin blue light increased
pigment and caused dark spots on the
skin while red light didn't so far it
seems that blue and violet light are the
colors of visible light that caused the
most damage to skin and it seems like
they caused this damage by producing
nitric oxide free radicals these free
radicals are really reactive because
they have an unpaired electron which
means that they can attack other
substances in your skin like DNA and
proteins I've talked about free radicals
before in my video on antioxidants that
I've linked in the caption below there's
a lot of different types of damage that
free radicals can cause they can slow
down skin cell production and they can
break down collagen for example so with
all this free radical damage you end up
with damaged skin that looks more uneven
in texture even though both visible
light and UV light both cause skin
damage it's important to note that they
have different effects on your skin so
you can't compare the two types of
light directly for example visible light
doesn't directly damage DNA but UV does
visible light also doesn't cause the
same microscopic changes in your skin
that UV does UV for example increases
inflammatory interleukin 8 and tumor
necrosis factor-alpha and p53 which is a
tumor protein that suppresses cancer
both UV and visible light caused
pigmentation or skin darkening in people
with darker skin but the pigment caused
by visible light lasts longer than the
pigment caused by the longer wavelengths
of UV called UVA1 the exact color of
the pigment is also different UVA1
causes your skin to get a grayish
pigment that slowly turns brown after a
while but visible light causes pigment
that's brown straight away
you also need different amounts or doses
of UV and visible light to have a
noticeable effect on skin each particle
or photon of UV has more energy than
each photon of visible light so again
it's like a bullet versus a balled up
tissue but the total energy to have an
effect on your skin is also different so
with the tissue analogy not only do you
need enough balls of tissue to get the
same weight as a bullet you actually
need a whole lot more different studies
have found that you need between 8 and
30 times as much visible light as UV in
terms of the units for light energy
which is joules per square centimeter
the effects of visible light also
depends on the type of skin you have in
terms of skin tone
in one study none of the tested
amounts of visible light caused
pigmentation in people with light
fitzpatrick II skin but people with
darker fitzpatrick IV to VI skin
developed more pigment the smallest
amount of visible light that causes
pigmentation in all of the dark-skinned
people in one study was 40 joules per
square centimeter this translates to
about 30 minutes of sunlight in midday
in summer in Texas one theory for why
visible light has different effects on
dark skin and light skin is that visible
light might interact with melanin to
form damaging free radicals the ones
that I talked about earlier so if you
want to protect your skin from visible
light what can you do you might have
guests with mineral sunscreens that
contain zinc oxide and titanium dioxide
but that's not quite right
even though a lot of people call these
ingredients physical blockers they don't
actually work that way they mostly work
just like organic also called chemical
sunscreens that absorb some wavelengths
so even in studies where they used a
really thick layer of mineral sunscreen
they still didn't protect against
visible light but there are some
ingredients that can help iron oxide
which is used as the main pigment in
foundations is effective at protecting
your skin against visible light but
there isn't a standard for measuring how
well any sort of product protects
against visible light so there isn't a
well-used measure for how well something
protects against visible light like how
we have SPF for UVB and PPD for UVA
since visible light causes damage via
free radicals antioxidants can also soak
them up which I've talked about before
in another video the one that I've
linked in the description one study
found that the free radicals from
visible light were halved when an
antioxidant mixture with vitamin E and
feverfew
and soy was used on people's skin and
just like with UV avoiding exposure to
light can work better than just using
skin care products you can stay in the
shade
you can wear hats and clothes as well to
protect your skin from visible light
damage and that's all for today's video
I hope you liked it and you learned
something new next time I'll be talking
about whether or not you should be
worried about skin damage from blue
light from screens like your laptop
phone tablet or computer stay tuned to
find out more as always subscribe follow
yay science see you next time for more
nerding